all right um so I am Kirsten Jones I am
the API Ninja at threescale that was my
requested title I actually have swag to
to uh I was planning on Bravely tossing
this into the
um and to the audience if you guys ask
good questions but I think that when my
minion gets back my API ninja in
training I will have her bring them out
because I don't actually want to cause
any harm to anybody here so
um I am a developer evangelist at three
scale uh we provide API Management
Services we're located right here in San
Francisco we have offices in London and
in Barcelona as well
previously I just started at three scale
I'm really excited at the opportunity to
sort of help people as a whole get
better at using apis and being
successful with them so previously I
worked at Netflix and Linkedin and I
have lots of experience helping
developers try to work with apis that
they found frustrating or difficult I am
a language polyglot so no Ruby is not my
first nor my second nor actually my
third language but and I may have given
this talk in other languages before but
I promise
there's lots of cool cool stuff here for
you in fact as I was working through
this talk for rails I was really
impressed with how much of the rest
fundamentals were used in designing
rails and so while I'm talking through
what I'm talking through tonight you may
find that you get a little bit more
insight into what the rails folks were
trying to do when they put together the
framework in the first place
so where I came from I am one of those
people who doesn't have a computer
science degree I have a ba in Philosophy
from UCSC Uncle Charlie's summer camp
for those of you who went there
and and I started working I actually
worked at SGI for a while I went to the
w3c conference in 93 in darmstadt and
I've been working with the web since
then but mostly what I do what I love to
do is help people solve problems find
barriers that are in people's way of
getting done what they want to get done
things that are frustrating them and
remove those barriers so they can do the
amazing things that they want to do so
that's what I love to do and that's what
I'm hoping to do here today
so this talk
um it's actually a little closer to http
deconstructed uh but what I discovered
when I was working at Netflix and at
LinkedIn was that a lot of people who
were incredibly intelligent programmers
they would come under the forums and
they'd be like so I I tried to get a
profile and it didn't work
and I'd say what did the HTTP stack look
like and they'd say
what the what a lot of people are
installing these libraries and they're
trying to use them but they don't
understand what the underlying
technology looks like historically
speaking apis have been for computers
talking to computers and there hasn't
been a good way for us to sort of
inspect what's going on one of the great
things about rest web services is that
it's not a black box you can inspect it
you can see what's going on and if you
have a little bit of understanding about
how HTTP works you can solve a lot of
problems without having to wait for
those Forum people to get back and
answer your questions so I'm going to
give you a little bit of those that
information I'm also going to show you a
couple tools that you can use to inspect
your own calls and figure out what's
going on get on with doing the
awesomeness that you want to do as
opposed to trying to beat your head
against the the stack of the the request
so I'm going to talk about a quick
overview HTTP how rest is layered on top
of that and then I'll go over debugging
tips and techniques and if you promise
to be nice and not ask me a bunch of
Ruby specific questions I'll take a lot
of questions at the end and if you ask
good questions I will have my lovely
minion here bring you uh oh I didn't
show you the swag you don't know that
you need it
your very own API Ninja
super cool
okay so um I see that most of you are
are very polite attendees and you don't
have your laptops out but a few of you
have your laptops and that's cool
because I also like to
poke at what the people are talking
about
um if you want to play along you're
welcome to you can go ahead and install
one of the HTTP sniffers HTTP scoop only
works on the Mac it's gorgeous it looks
totally Macky it doesn't support SSL you
have to use something like Charles which
is really kind of complicated to use SSL
so you can get that at www.tuffcode.com
or for Windows you can use Fiddler
uh it's not as beautiful because it's a
Windows product but on the other hand it
does support SSL natively and it gives
you a lot of great information if you
use Linux I didn't put it on the screen
but you can use Wireshark which is
uglier than anything but
does is more fully functional than
either of these so
and I'm going to talk through what HTTP
sniffers do and how they can help you
figure out what's going on
okay HTTP
um most of you probably know this stuff
it'll be pretty quick
for those of you who don't HTTP is the
hypertext transfer protocol from named
by people who like to camel case things
and throw capitals in the middle of
things
the the basic way to describe it is it's
a used for conversations between web
clients and servers and it supports
verbs for get put post and delete
there's a few other verbs as well
they're not as widely used not as
supported by as many clients but try to
keep these in mind because this is
interesting in how it Maps later on to
the rest verbs
and one of the cool things is it
supports includes support for query
parameters which allows you to add a
little bit more information to a request
it also includes some excellent error
handling
okay so let's talk through this really
quickly we have a request and a response
the client sends a request it has a
method which as I said is one of those
verbs get put post delete there's a URL
that's the that's the
um
identifier for the the thing what's
really cool about the way rest uses HTTP
and the way HTTP works is the URL is the
identifier for the resource you're
trying to get
um some headers giving some meta
information about what you want
parameters optionally and
sometimes a body
server replies a response
it's always going to have a status
usually it's going to have a content for
instance with a delete it's not going to
have a a
Content but in general you're going to
get some content back and then some
headers telling the client about
information about that resource
this is one of my favorite slides I had
to clean it up a little bit after I gave
this talk at ozcon and got scolded by
someone
but this is very helpful for those
people who haven't spent a lot of time
looking at this uh 500 we we messed up
uh 400 I I actually I think the better a
better way to describe it is huh what
um 30X is asked that dude over there and
two o x is that's cool
um one of the cool things about 40x is
is uh as a server
um the the server has the opportunity to
provide a lot of interesting status
codes the authentication ones 401 is
different than a 403 one of them is the
authentication isn't allowed we've got
404 where it's not there we have 418
which uh anybody know what 418 is
I'm a Little Teapot that's right so uh
there's a HTTP status code for just
about everything
yeah you gotta say you you think the w3c
doesn't have a sense of humor I'm a
Little Teapot made it into the spec
okay so again I'll try to go through
this quickly because this stuff on
slides is not beautiful but it should
give you an idea
um so we've we're asking for stuff from
Google
um your browser sends all of this crap
all of the time
um this is one of the one of the coolest
things you can do with a sniffer is to
just run your browser and see what's
happening find out what kind of
information the browser and the server
are passing back and forth about you you
wonder what those cookies are and what
they're storing this is really helpful
so this is the request
and here's the response
so there's a bunch of data but other
than the stuff that you see in your
screen you've got the status you've got
the content which is a bunch of HTML but
we also know what the content type is of
what's coming back
um what the Char set is that actually
tells the browser information about how
it could render it
um
it sets it may optionally set a cookie
to store information later
anyway so that kind of gives you an idea
of the volume of information that goes
back and forth when all you're doing is
clicking on things in your browser
and um
this microphone and I are not great
friends yet
um so this is HTTP scoop
one of the reasons I really like it is
that it's really quite friendly
um the default is it just shows you the
things that are happening and when you
click on it it shows you
you know here's the here's the response
line including the status here's the URL
when there's parameters they're going to
be over here
was there a body in the request no it's
a get so there wasn't anybody how big
was the response and what was the
response time
this is actually even useful if you're
just trying to um do some
troubleshooting on your very own server
like why is my server not doing what I'm
expecting well let's get some data let's
just poke around of course you can you
can run tests you can run automated
systems on it but sometimes just poking
around at it and getting some data about
that
can give you information that will help
you solve a problem
okay so now we have some headers
this is that fabulous
um
Gmail request and that shows you the the
the headers
um but what's cool is it shows you the
request headers over here the response
headers over here again giving you
information so that you can determine
why things aren't working the way you
expect
Okay so
I'm gonna move on
wow everything's so big all of a sudden
Okay so
as I was saying rest apis leverage HTTP
and for those of you who have used rails
significantly you probably noticed that
rails uses the same sort of a language
when you tell it how to do a route you
tell it which HTTP verb to use
essentially
you have a get you have a delete
for error codes
it uses HTTP status codes for request
parameters that you need for any API it
leverages the query parameters and for
response types and configuration it it
leverages headers one example of this
that's really useful is
a lot of
apis actually support XML or Json
one way for them to have the clients
tell the server what they want is to
send a header that says I want XML or I
want Json that is exactly what those
headers were used were designed for is
to send meta information about the
request that says how that information
should come back that's used most
frequently it's been used historically
for languages and other things like that
but there's no reason you can't leverage
that that framework to make your API
smarter
so
having said that we'll look at an
example rest request there aren't a lot
of apis that do not require
very tricky authentication but Tumblr
allows you to do read requests without
doing the oauth dance and since we have
a limited amount of time here tonight
I'm not going to try to describe oauth
um so you're making the the sample
request
the API key was the only parameter
that's going in it's got the request URL
as you can see it looks just like a
browser request
you can see that the the under headers
the request headers are very simple
your your API client is very rarely
going to send extra headers it's only
going to send things that needs to send
it in this case it doesn't have much to
say it is saying what kind of user agent
it is
that's just because curl is sending that
we actually if we could send it with a
um using a different functionality it
wouldn't even put in the user agent but
the response headers are still coming
through we still see that the content
type is application Json we um it's it's
giving us
um
some internal tumbler information and
the date of the request
and you can see the response text is
much easier to see in this screen and
this is just a Json response notice one
of the things that that apis tend to do
is is they they shove some meta
information in the in the request but
you're still always going to get a
status code back from the server the
server doesn't know how to respond to
you without giving you the status code
okay so that basically is a whirlwind uh
description of how HTTP Works how rest
works and is layered on top of it most
versions of this talk when I have a
whole hour to talk I go through oauth
oauth is a pain there are excellent
libraries libraries out there and I
cannot possibly do anything in 10
minutes with somebody who doesn't know
oauth other than horribly confuse you
and make you never want to do it so um I
promise you if you need to use a web
service that uses oauth there is a
fantastic Library available I know that
the the Ruby libraries especially not
just oauth libraries um when does anyone
know there's there is somebody who does
a great job of making API libraries for
almost every API in Ruby and he he
supports them and he does a fantastic
job
when
yes Penguin
that's him
right
p-e-n-g-w-y-n-n so he's he made a uh I
know he of him because when I was at
LinkedIn he made a great LinkedIn
um gym but he also
um makes goes out of his way to make
sure and find apis that need
Ruby love and give it to them so
you always want to
um
try to find those libraries
and I'll mention more about that in just
a moment
Okay so
um
troubleshooting API calls
first uh use HTTP scoop or Fiddler or
Wireshark if you don't have a Mac
to understand your calls I encourage you
to watch your traffic on browsers watch
your traffic with your clients
spend a lot of time looking at how
traffic works so that you really
understand how that HTTP stuff works
if you find a call a known good call
and you have a call that seems the same
to you but isn't working there is
something different about it the server
does not have something against you
personally I know it feels like it when
you're trying to get stuff done you're
like oh man this server just got it in
for me it doesn't there's something
different you may have misspelled one of
the parameters you may have put things
in the wrong order
I'm going to talk about using libraries
and one some of the reasons for that in
just a moment
um
so compare it against a known good call
that's your best strategy in almost all
cases with apis
simplify your request sometimes you've
got a parentheses in your call or you've
got a space in your call and the library
that you're using or the code that you
have isn't gracefully handling that in
the way that the API expects so make it
the simplest call you possibly can see
if it works then
binary testing it's always always the
best way to go about it
and then so here I'll I'll uh I'll break
off and tell you a little story about
asking good questions
um
one of the things I always want to do
whenever I'm trying to support a
developer or help someone with something
is help them right away they wouldn't be
asking me a question if they weren't
frustrated so they're already frustrated
and what I hate the most is when they're
they like ask me a question and then I
ask them a question and then they ask me
a question and then I ask them a
question they ask me a question
so when you ask questions especially on
stack Overflow where people are not the
kindest always
you want to ask good questions so what
is a good question look like stack
Overflow has a great description but
it's not nearly as amusing as mine
so
first I'll tell you what you want to
what what you want how you want to ask
the question and then I'll tell you why
so ask a question
I did a I expected B to happen to my
dismay
C happened instead
Okay so
that seems obvious right
um why would I have to put B in there
though because I did a and then C
happened in fact why do I even need to
say a
so I jumped off a cliff I expected to
sprout wings and fly
to my dismay I plunged to my death
instead
not really a bug in gravity
it's actually
I misunderstood the system
and what I want users to realize is
that's still a bug
the the job of the people supporting the
API is to make sure that your
expectations are set correctly so if you
thought that you were going to sprout
wings and fly then probably somewhere in
the documentation there should be a note
that says you're not
probably
it's still the support person's problem
but you can help them help you and you
can help them help you right now instead
of 17 iterations down the road when
you're both ready to tear each other's
hair out if you put all of these things
out right away especially on stack
overflow with the less kind people but
in general this is a really good way to
make sure and it also helps you because
sometimes you're like I did a I expect
oh
never mind
you know I mean sometimes you see what
your problem is when you try to explain
it in a way that really makes it clear
you make it clear and then you realize
right that's not how that works
Okay so
troubleshooting API calls that's one
thing I can I can help you with but the
second thing is my favorite part
ing preventable problems
so use existing libraries code and
examples
at some point in your in your life as an
API developer or API user you may think
I'm going to write an oauth Library
don't
and then you might think no no really
I'm I'm the person who's going to do it
right don't don't just don't do it there
are fantastic libraries out there for
all of the big languages in most of the
languages and certainly Ruby is one of
the big languages that has fantastic
libraries there are so many rules about
oauth like did you know
here let me tell you one of the things
now
because of the way the signatures are
generated
the parameters not only do they have to
be in alphabetical order but if you have
multiple parameters of the same name
they have to be an alphabetical order of
the values
or the signatures won't match
really seriously there's a corner case
you're not going to test for
Until It Breaks which it will because
you don't want to write your own Library
you have great ideas you have fantastic
applications inside of you spend your
time on that don't spend your time
rewriting oauth libraries
code defensively okay we all hear that
all the time code defensively that's a
thing they say In Those computer science
classes I didn't take
but we all know that we're perfect right
so since we own the whole stack top to
bottom there's no chance we're going to
actually hose ourselves and cause
something to break you know elsewhere
but you know okay well if it were true
that we were always perfect and never
made any mistakes
even so you are no longer in Con in
control of your whole stack when you're
using an API you have to assume they're
going to mess you up so you have to
assume that just because that field has
always shown up before in this Json
representation if it's not if it doesn't
say in the spec that that's what's going
to happen it could go away it could
disappear
and if it all if it was always if it
always had a value before and then was
empty if it was zero that's not
necessarily true either so you want to
test that does it exist and is it zero
does it exist and does it have this
value
assume that they're going to change
everything they don't say they're going
to change and also the things they say
they're not going to change check those
two
test defensively write tests
write your integration tests so that
they also cover the API stuff make sure
that when you write those tests you're
not just testing your own code you're
testing the code with the apis on the
back end so that when they change
something and it changes and it breaks
your stuff you know right away
that's the test frequently part and
handle errors gracefully
one of the things that is most useful is
to pass those errors back so obviously
you most things you don't want to pass
back to the user but if you can log them
somewhere on your own server so that you
can so that when you ask for help from
the support team and they're like well
what did it send back and you're like I
don't know
they're gonna be like yeah yeah come
back to me when you can recreate it and
show me what the what the what the stack
looked like so save yourself that are
that that
um trouble and go ahead what was the
call what was it two what were the
parameters whose key was it what did it
do and what did the error look like and
if I know anything about behind
everything just put it all in there
you'll think yourself later or you'll
run out of disk space and you'll blame
me but that's okay discs are cheap
frustration is expensive so
uh that's that's it I I will give you
guys an opportunity to get ninjas in a
moment
um so it's me I am Senator on Twitter oh
man I always mean to tell you all to say
nice things about me on on Twitter so
that my boss will be happy
um I am Kirsten atrescale.net the API
ninja
um I will be uh giving a talk on uh
intro to apis at the API strategy
conference here in San Francisco if you
have interest incoming.com friends um
come after and see me and I will uh pass
you along to our conference organizers
um my website is princesspollymath.com I
am princess polymath
um
and thanks so much to twilio for hosting
it's very expensive to feed all these
people and keep people here after hours
and I just want you guys to remember and
and uh and appreciate
um how awesome it is when they do that
so thanks very much and I will ask
questions